well not surprisingly the city of San
Francisco has some of this country's
most far-out sanctuary city laws so far
out that even a fairly left-wing mayoral
candidate is fed up with them Angela
Alioto is collecting signatures for a
fall ballot initiative who would scale
back the city's sanctuary policies
policies that for years she's supported
broadly currently city law blocks the
police from reporting even habitual
criminals and those suspected of
felonies to federal immigration
authorities now ladies Alioto says that
needs to change as the city is becoming
a magnet for illegal immigrants who are
also dangerous criminals
Angela Alioto joins us tonight as well
thanks a lot for coming on so I just
find this it's measure
I doubt you and I agree on politically
which is why I wanted to talk to you I
don't think that you consider yourself a
conservative that's probably true I do
so I guess the headline here is the
headline is the policies in your city
are so crazy that even you who support
sanctuary city says enough is that a
fair assessment I not only support
sanctuary city I wrote the law
I wrote the law in 1991 and it was
amended in 2016 to add felons
why would someone amend it to add felons
people who are demonstrably dangerous to
the citizens and taxpayers of your city
what was the idea there I have
absolutely no idea but as the author of
the sanctuary law I find it totally
unacceptable and so in writing this
ordinance for the November ballot that
says that dangerous and serious felonies
are simply not going to be allowed to
have the protection of a sanctuary law I
mean it it absolutely makes no sense
that the elected officials of San
Francisco don't understand what the
people of San Francisco want and what
they want is to not have felons
protected but the elected officials want
to protect the felons so I mean that is
that's kind of the question in a
democracy big policy should have popular
support are there hundreds of thousands
tens of thousands dozens of San
Franciscans who say you know what I want
my city to protect dangerous felons not
that I know of because I've been out on
the case
faint rail for five months and I talked
to people about the fact that my
sanctuary law was amended to add not
only misdemeanors and felonies but
dangerous and serious felonies with up
to three within seven years some
ridiculous wording and the people are
aghast they're like they don't even know
that that's what was in the sanctuary
law but when they find out that it's in
it they're really shocked and I have
great support from the people however
from the elected officials they had a
press conference two hours ago
all of them lined up in front of City
Hall I
you know condemning me and calling me
names basically because I want to take
felons out of the sanctuary laws such
that they are not protected should they
commit a serious or dangerous felony it
just is so what are they saying about I
mean that's it's like a bare minimum for
governance if you're in charge of a city
you ought to be putting the protection
of your people ahead of everything else
no so what were they calling you well
I've been called a Nazi I've been called
trumpian I've been called a fascist I've
been called a racist I'm a civil rights
lawyer I've won more civil rights
verdicts throughout this nation in the
last 18 years then I won the largest
civil rights verdict against Wonderbread
and then to be called a racist and a
Nazi and a fascist because I'm taking
felonies felonies against children
felonies against two other human beings
out of the sanctuary law I wrote that
was intended to protect families and
children staying together in San
Francisco once they got here
undocumented so the entire intent of my
sanctuary law went out the window when
they amended it and added felonies and
right now they're trying to make the
community think I'm trying to abolish
the sanctuary law itself so now certain
communities are up in arms and it's it's
blatantly absurd I am gonna go forward
so when you walk through living right I
hope you and we're rooting for I've
never thought I would say this about
anything you're for but I'm rooting for
you in this case but quickly since
you're from San Francisco for this but
then all the time you walk down the
street
you see junkies shooting up you go to
you know Union Square and there people
living there and defecating on the
sidewalk of the cities protecting felons
and normal people are leaving because
they can't afford it do you think I
don't recognize this place do you ever
think that to yourself like what city is
this
well again I'm a mother of four the
grandmother of five a very successful
civil rights attorney if you told me a
year and a half ago I was gonna run for
mayor again I would have said I don't
think so
but I have to tell you walking through
the streets seeing such poverty on the
streets something I've already addressed
before and was extremely successful at
addressing seeing this unbelievable
outbreak of people sticking needles in
their arms and then slumping over and
other people just walking by and going
to their jobs it's totally unacceptable
to me that will not happen when I'm
mayor I will take them off the street
and give them the care they need we
don't need anymore money we have the
money in the budget but to walk by and
pretend that it's okay that San
Francisco our iconic city in the world
looks like you know a third world
country with people on the streets dying
is horrible it that's why I'm ready you
know what you better see you better stop
there because I'm about to send you a
campaign contribution because I can't do
it but I want you because what you're
saying makes sense Angela alia I know I
can't believe I'm saying nice thank you
but I really am God blood Godspeed good
luck well listen Talib please go to WWII
in felony reporting did that but I'm I'm
rooting for you
thanks a million up next a new study
shows that climate models may have
exaggerated carbon driven global warming
by as much as 45% that's science why
haven't you heard about that will tell
you next